這裡是AI101,全網最幽默的AI新聞。
美國和俄羅斯聯手,在最後關頭削弱了聯合國的殺手機器人安全文件。
原本的安全文字,被刪成內容大幅弱化的版本,說起來很諷刺。
美國和俄羅斯在烏克蘭戰爭中分屬對立陣營,可是一道日內瓦談判桌。
卻站到同一邊,反對更具體、有約束力的國際規則。
美俄黨下的,到底是什麼規則?
是致命自主武器
英文所寫Loss
能在操作員不介入時
自行選擇並攻擊目標
所以關鍵在於
機器已經找到目標
排好順序時
人類還有沒有最後決定權
這可不是隻上談兵
華盛頓郵報報道
Palantir的Maven
整合Anthropic The Cloud
為美軍及時選目標與排序提供支援
2月28日展開的實施怒火行動
首24小時攻擊超過1000個伊朗目標
平均每86秒一個
就在同一天
伊朗米納布一所小學遭到攻擊
至少165人死亡
很多是孩童
美方初步調查
指向過時的目標資料
這些資料在加速的目標鏈裡
一路通過了人類遷河
所以
有人遷河
不代表複合就有效
照理說
這正是國際規則該管的事
可是在特定常規武器公約底下
各國從2014年開始談
談了十多年
到現在還沒有專門針對致命自主武器
具有法律約束力的國際規則
為什麼會卡這麼久
其實想開談的國家是多數
共有76國
支持以這份文本為基礎開談
但制度採供時絕
只要一國反對就卡住
文件只能一直退讓
最後那一步退讓
發生在9月4日
主席宣佈停表
聯合國的公開鏡頭
幾乎到此為止
《華盛頓郵報》報道
美國和俄羅斯閉門約15小時
逐條改稿
到9月5日凌晨才達成共識
那15個小時
刪掉了什麼
《華盛頓郵報》的獨家調查指出
其中一條是AI產生的目標
在攻擊前必須由人類複合
這一條被刪了
被拿掉的還不止這一條
6月5日的公開文本
還寫著倫理考量
武器系統也應該可預測
可靠
可追溯
可解釋
人權觀察組織指出
這些字眼在最後報告裡全被移除
並直接點名美國和俄羅斯
一路刪下來
9月由128個締約方接受的
只剩一份
沒有法律約束力的原素文件
這份文件不是條約
也不代表各國同意開始談條約
美國國內也在拉扯
Anthropic執行長Dario Amodei
替Cloud畫了兩條紅線
不做大規模國內監控
不做全自主武器
國防部長Pete Hexeth
卻把這家公司列為供應鏈風險
這場衝突鬧上了法院
8月
加州聯邦法官裁定政府
以較廣泛措施
懲罰Anthropic違法
可是9月25日
華府聯邦上訴法院
在另案又以2比1
支持五角大廈
依另一部供應鏈法排除Anthropic
目前沒有誰全勝
法院沒有定論
國際規則也還沒定
11月16日到20日
各國會再回日內瓦
決定要展開有約束力的議定書談判
還是繼續討論
真正要問的是
人類還來不來得及
把最後一道有效複合
寫進國際規則
追蹤AI101
不錯過AI圈的最新消息